now time is running out to save the
planet a landmark u.n climate report
says there is no doubt that human
activities are contributing to raising
the global surface temperature
the report shows that efforts to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions have been
insufficient over the past decades and
the earth is now warmer than it's been
in thousands of years
africa remains the most vulnerable
continent despite contributing the least
to greenhouse gas emissions across the
continent climate change felt through
recurring floods and droughts is
producing millions of refugees each year
now in a moment we'll be talking to an
expert about what needs to be done but
let's first take you to western kenya
where our correspondent maria mueller
reports that flats have created a
humanitarian crisis
what looks like a lake used to be
farmland
dozens of homesteads are now underwater
this is the first time dorothy akini has
returned to the ruins of her house
she worked long and hard
now everything is gone
i want to cry i built this house not
long ago i have no means to rebuild it
i borrow money every day
i have to beg for food
i'm begging to rebuild my house
but there's not even land for italian
it's been known for decades that river
nando in western kenya is prone to
overflowing but it has always been
manageable says dorothy aquini it never
threatened her farm
dorothy has been living here for over 20
years but in 2017 everything changed her
house and her entire livelihood has been
destroyed she's convinced it is
connected to climate change but with no
help from the government she and 600
other families depend now on aid
donations
the floods caused people to move to this
camp a few kilometers away
conditions are bad
people live just in one meal a day
there's hardly any medical help and the
risk of typhoid and malaria infection is
high because of water contamination
elizabeth arbonnio lives here with her
three children
the children are always sick i find them
sleeping all the time
when i ask them what's up they say mommy
my head mommy my head
but we don't have money to buy medicine
or even money to take them to hospital
this is the fifth time they have been
displaced due to flooding
it seems to be a never-ending cycle and
it seems little is being done to prevent
it
the only thing that could help dorothy
and the others in the long term would be
to build a dam
she recalls a visit by a government
minister
you know
minister eugene vamaya came to the camp
by helicopter he said they would release
money to build this dam
so when the water comes this way it
won't come back to our land and displace
us
but they have done nothing now
we take dorothy's statement to the
minister in nairobi
so what is your reaction to that yes we
have had this problem for quite a while
we have the long-term solution to this
which is really building a dam that
would cost to think over 20 billion it's
going to be a huge dam this
administration has actually prioritized
it and i'm very happy that
before the end of this year we should be
able to get it underway
he expects it to be completed in three
to four years and he promises cash
payments for the vulnerable
but elizabeth erbono doesn't believe
that she wants to know why it has taken
the government so long to act
she'd like to move to a safer area to
provide her children with a stable home
if you don't have money you have to
stick to the place that's yours no
matter how bad it is because you have no
means to go and rent a house
so we are forced to die in this place no
matter how bad it is
all she has is the hope that the
minister is true to his word
joining me now is the executive director
of the pan-african climate justice
alliance dr mithika wenda hello and
welcome to the program dr muenda now we
just saw a report about western kenya's
nyanza area facing constant flooding and
residents believe it's getting worse due
to climate change do you agree
of course it is caused by climate change
but also there are other causes of
course which combines with this that is
a cause of deforestation uh and under
land degradation due to to
overpopulation so there are so many
factors but really climate is one of the
factors
well that's definitely in line with what
the latest u.n climate report says it
suggests that human activities are
largely responsible for worsening
climate change what is driving climate
change in africa
well
it's not in africa alone but globally we
know the cause of climate change is is a
combination of many factors and it's
about the the the the the the the
amount of production and the consumption
which we have
we have obtained since the industrial
revolution that um we are we are pumping
a lot of greenhouse uh gases into the
atmosphere which in inter interfere with
the uh at the mo at the atmosphere and
that basically what we are saying that
when if we want to reverse these causes
we have really to live within the
planetary boundaries and that's actually
what this report says we have been
talking about it but uh well who listens
because we know the solution
but we have remained indifferent to
acting on it okay interesting what you
say who listens and we have the
solutions we'll be getting to possible
solutions later but uh back to africa
what are the worst affected areas on the
continent and how are they
affected
the
the key areas uh as you may be aware
right now you know countries like
algeria in northern north africa now are
completely inundated by by by the
changing climate you see uh
in the past you you haven't seen the
hurricane
the cyclone kenneth in southern africa
countries like mozambique and and ziba
they have never recovered as we speak
even now to release billions of dollars
while we stand and the people are still
picking from that in eastern africa you
are you you will see persistent drought
there the eastern and on of africa so
these are things which are served in
fact i normally say that we don't now
need scientists to tell us that things
are changing they are observable and we
really need to do something particularly
in africa which is the most vulnerable
and of course has contributed
very minimally very negligible to the
impact to the cause of climate crisis
i'll pick it up from your last words we
need to do something here's the thing
africa has enormous hydro power
potential enough sunshine why isn't the
continent harnessing this wealth of
renewable sources of energy
the bottom line here is lack of
resources and number two lack of
political will both at global level and
this we know the solution of this is
renewable energy why are we not
transitioning why not are we not uh
divesting from fossil fuels yeah
renewables because we know these are the
solutions for me for me say
that sounds really like an excuse i
think the main challenge is the lack of
the political will because if there was
the political will then of course
wherever the money will be gotten from
we will find that to invest in that
right
exactly precisely let me tell you and
actually
that's the campaign we have been
mounting particularly to the
industrialized countries they have been
saying that there is no money to to to
invest in climate action to for
mitigation and adaptation in africa and
building resilience in for the
communities like the communities i come
from
there is a lot of money and the coffee
19 actually assured us that within a
record time
these industrialized countries were
able to to mobilize trillions of dollars
within a short time a year to develop
the vaccine and of course now to to to
for for post covent reconstruction we
are asking if they were able to do that
why did they do that why are they saying
there is no money in on
to address climate it is because they
don't see climate change as their
problem they think that it is african
problem but i want to challenge them
look at what is happening in the
netherlands right now look at what's
happening in germany look at what's
elsewhere and many other countries in
the north they the difference between
that and and algeria is that algeria has
no capacity they have capacity but at
the end of the day they are being
affected one time okay they are going to
sync with it it is not going to be to be
useful so it's not a favor to address
climate change it is a problem a global
problem we have to address it
collectively just as we have done in
covingt okay you're talking about a more
collaborative effort let's wrap it up
now with uh aggressive action that
should be taken now to avoid the most
dire effects of climate change
this one
is beyond resilience of communities
because we cannot reverse this this the
the the climate impacts we cannot
reverse we have to build resilience so
that these communities can survive that
requires sufficient resources and of
course technology and capacity for these
communities two
deep
emission cuts in the at the source even
if you give us money or to to offset
emissions in congo forest or amazon or
elsewhere when you are not addressing it
at us level
at the most emitting countries i don't
think we're addressing it so this has
two so we need really deep emission cuts
and that should be done in
industrialized countries you need to
change the amount of production and
consumption and because that is where
the problem is once we address that then
we are going to really uh bequeath the
future and the generation you know habit
of the planet and as you are the health
of planet and this survivor for humanity
okay dr mithy kamuenda
director of pan-african climate justice
alliance thank you thank you thank you